you know one of my really important
colleagues on my team one of my managers
Karen VZ
she suggested I read the book The
Alchemist and it changed my whole life
because I realized all of the people who
had conspired to get me to this place oh
I love The Alchemist man that book is it
will change your life it's the one you
know what it why because it absolutely
shows you that if you have the desire
the universe will rise up to meet you
exactly where you are yeah oh yes yeah
yes you have to be unafraid to dream
right and then you have to be even more
brave and gallant about blueprinting
what you've envisage t' yes you gotta be
brave about that so you read the
alchemist and then it was like clear to
me I was like wow thank you guys so much
for watching my hope with this new
series is by learning what these
successful entrepreneurs are reading
maybe some of that knowledge can pass on
to you and you could pick up the same
books and improve yourselves so I'd love
to know one have you read The Alchemist
I've got to add it to my list because so
many people have talked about how great
a book it is have you read it do you
enjoy it yes or no what do you think
about it and - what books are you
currently reading now that our exciting
for you that you want to share that you
think every entrepreneur should read
leave both of those in the comments
below I'll join the discussion thank you
so much for watching you seem to believe
and I'll see you soon